one of the greatest mysteries over much
of the souls franchise has been who the
first son of Gwyn is a God of War and
heir to the sunlight who is stripped of
deity and whose very name has been lost
from the annals of history well now we
know this god of War's identity he is
the nameless king the ring of the sons
firstborn has given some description of
Quinns son throughout the whole series
in Dark Souls 3 it states the sons
firstborn was once a God of War until he
was stripped of the stature as
punishment for his foolishness no wonder
his very name has slipped from the
annals of history so we now have some
current justification for my opening
claims the golden crown of the nameless
king is said to closely resemble that of
the first Lord
the first Lord being Gwyn yet what
really confirmed the nameless king as
the son of the first Lord is his soul
which reads the nameless king was once a
dragon slaying god of war before he
sacrificed everything to ally himself
put the ancient dragons wins firstborn
was likely accompanying him on the
battlefield during the war with the
ancient dragons but now we see what when
Sons foolishness was that caused him to
be disgraced and forgotten from history
he sided with the dragons he sacrificed
everything and that he gave up his
entire life family and inheritance to
side with his father's enemies but why
would he do this killing the eternal
dragons lid gwin's start the age of fire
and entered the world into a prosperous
time yet his son didn't see it as the
right choice perhaps this is because the
former king and war god tamed the storm
Dre in which he led a lifetime of battle
this could mean that because of the
friendship the nameless King had with
the storm Drake we fight during his
phase one he had sympathy for the
Dragons I did not want to see them
destroyed or maybe like the Knights of
lothric the nameless king saw the
potential in taming the great winged
beasts but could not convince his father
of their use I think there's definitely
some push towards the idea of the
friendship between the king and his
storm Drake as the storm curved sword
relates the nameless King ally of the
ancient dragons
fought beside the storm Drake in
countless battles when the Great Beast
fell the king claimed his soul as was
the custom in the age of gods after a
lifetime of battles the two must have
been close this is truly seen when the
player-character fails the Drake before
claiming his soul a nameless King
caresses the beasts arm in an almost
somber moment hesitating to deliver the
final blow and absorb his soul nameless
king also had some history with
Dragonslayer Ornstein Ornstein was said
to be the first night of the sons eldest
born we now know to be the nameless king
through these similar references of war
God in both the nameless King and
Gwynn's firstborn
additionally the weapon that the name
was gang wields the Dragon Slayer sword
spear is the earliest form of the cross
spear orange Dean's weapon of choice is
a lightning imbued cross spear which he
used during the time of the dragon war
and as such is called the Dragon Slayer
spear so chances are Ornstein spear is a
direct result of the nameless Kings
what's most impactful in Dark Souls 3 in
the story of orange scene and the
nameless King is that orange scenes
armor can be found at the site of the
nameless Kings boss light his helm tells
us what happened in the dragon Lesage so
the current age were now this knight who
long guarded the ruined Cathedral left
the land in search of the nameless King
so Ornstein left his post in Anor Londo
to find his old master there can be
speculation as to why arnt seemed wanted
to see the nameless king he could have
been angry with his Lord for abandoning
his old life and siding with the
dragon's enemies of the gods or perhaps
Ornstein simply wanted to be reunited
with an old friend
finding Orton's armor here can imply
that he fought the nameless king and was
slain by him but I'm not so sure there's
no course where we found the armor just
a white item glow an orange scenes
weapon the Dragon Slayer spear is found
next to the entrance gates of his own
almost as if he laid down his weapon
before greeting his aged master Ornstein
and the nameless King definitely could
have fought and is likely that ornstein
would have lost the fight but personally
and this might just be wishful
thinking I believe they didn't from soft
is usually very direct with their
placement of items bodies etc so it
seems to me that this come together it
was less of an anger filled one and more
of a peaceful reunion of old friends but
that is basically just speculation and I
could be wrong
the nameless king is a ferocious
opponent he has amazing skill and
prowess and fighting after all he was a
God of War this is clearly evident in
his boss play which is probably one of
the hardest in the game his heritage
gifts him with affinity to lightning and
he demonstrates a mastery of it his
pinpoint lightning bolt throws in
mid-flight and his destructive powerful
lightning storm on foot he sacrificed
everything to do what he thought was
right and that's really all anyone can
do in this dreary world of Dark Souls
so the mysteries closed twins firstborn
isn't sole heir or any other previous
fan theory but the king of the storm a
nameless king